[Music]
all right Wow when you get back on the
grid you really get back on the grid we
are live for the second time today I am
the guy on the show wearing the shirt of
the show I'll get into that a little bit
more in just a second but I wanted to do
just a live stream just directly with
you guys it was great to sit down with
Ben and I knew that was gonna be fun I
knew who's gonna be kind of cathartic I
knew it was gonna be a little nutty it
was just gonna be a little bit of
everything because after not ingesting
the news since August first about 34
days obviously I had missed a lot but I
also had time personally to kind of work
on some things I wanted to work on clear
out some space in my brain
there was a one-week period so actually
the last week so all of last week before
I got back on ended up being a workweek
I wasn't on my computer and I was and
you know I wasn't doing anything
obviously on social media or emailing or
that kind of stuff but I was taking a
couple phone calls and we were doing a
lot of work here because as of today we
launched a new website Dave Rubin comm
which we had been trying to get for at
least 10 years maybe 15 years there's a
Dave Rubin in the middle of the country
somewhere who had this family website
but he slowly wasn't using it or he was
using a less and less over the course of
a couple years we're finally able to get
that from him so we now have Dave Rubin
comm so all things Rubin report you can
still go to Rubin report comm it's gonna
send you over to Dave Rubin comm and all
things Rubin report will be there you
can find out more about the show you can
also find out my live events I'm back
into stand-up again I'm on tour with
Petersen actually I leave tomorrow
morning to head out to Rochester
tomorrow then Long Island my home island
on the six then we're up in Connecticut
then on the eighth I'm doing an event in
New York City with with faysville Muhtar
who's been on the show and with Eric
Weinstein a couple other people I think
Melissa Chen is hosting that one anyway
there's just a ton of stuff going on it
was just incredible to be away for a bit
you know like I saw a couple people on
Twitter I'm actually only looked at my
Twitter mentions once or twice today but
I saw a couple people like oh how can
you say you're like a news person or in
the news or whatever and take time off
from all of this like you know
it's not possible and it's like actually
I feel I feel more clear on things now I
sense like a little bit of clarity with
some things and I think getting away
from the noise is as important is as
important as being part of it all the
time and I think everyone could use a
little bit of an escape more I think
part of the problem right now is that we
don't have enough escape so yeah so
launched a new website we redid the set
which was a tremendous amount of work so
we wanted the set to look a little bit
more like my my house itself we want it
to be a little more a little more slim
and trim America we've jumped to the
wide shot for a second is that possible
while we're doing this so we look giving
me a signal we can't do it okay we can't
do it that's alright all right well what
we're gonna do is I'm gonna talk a bit
about patreon in a second and we'll do
some behind the scenes video stuff on
patreon that'll that'll show you that
we're gonna do a picture we're gonna do
a picture okay yeah so we wanted to set
just to feel a little more a little more
minimal I love the set that we had
before we had it for about two years but
it's good to just freshen things up so
we've got new artwork on the wall the
picture that is behind me and behind the
guest or done by cailin rosa janet who's
done a bunch of artwork for us and i
have a lot of her art in my house these
shelves right here I don't want to brag
people all right you can bring it back
to her you know yeah either way the
shelves over there don't want to brag
but they are from Ikea and I do have a
bunch of them in my house in the middle
of the thing there we've got some of my
old stand up tapes from the late 90s
we've got every book that is now on the
set by the way is a book of a guest of
the Rubin report we thought that was
pretty cool before we had a mix of just
some other people who have influenced me
in things we have new carpet new table
new chairs we changed some lighting
things so basically it was just like a
big reinvestment in all the things that
we're doing here I think it's good to
just say I think it's good to reinvest
in things I think it's good visually
just to mix things up and I think I just
wanted I just felt like doing something
fresh after taking a big a big break
like this so a new website new set you
may have noticed we have a new theme
song so I found so one of the things I
was doing when I was off the grid
was I was listening to a lot of music
and I've lately really really been into
non vocal music so just you know like
music but no singing no words I get it
you love a girl you lost a girl okay
it's all good so I've really been into
synth Wave lately which I really liked I
always like these sort of long melodic
sort of futuristic II but kind of 80s
throwback music interludes that you know
the movie oblivion I really love the
soundtrack Tron the movie I love the
soundtrack you know there's a bunch of
this stuff out there so I was really
into synth wave and I came across this
guy Marvel 83 and I just loved
everything the guy was doing it was just
while I was away
it was just speaking to me the tenor of
it the tone of it it felt like sort of
real but also thoughtful and decent so
there was a song by him which you can
check out on YouTube later called Venice
Beach and that was the song that I
really wanted to be the theme song and
we laid it in a couple of times we
couldn't get it quite right so we ended
up going with another song called
every evening which I did just as much
and he's kind of sampling his own song
from that and he's a great guy and we
chatted a bit he's in the Czech Republic
so Marvel 83 if you're watching thank
you for the for the song so we
reinvested in all that and as you can
see we have a new graphics package so
the the video that you saw when we came
in and the lower thirds as we call them
in the guest name pop up and swipes and
all kinds of other stuff is all new but
the real big thing and then I'll take
your questions and I'll talk a little
bit more about being off the grid and
that kind of stuff the real big thing
that we relaunched today was we
relaunched our patreon now we got on
patreon in June I think of 2016 and I we
were basically the first of these sort
of political talk show things to be on
patreon it was a lot of video game
things it was a lot of more anime stuff
I don't know that kind of thing and we
jumped in and and I've told the story
before but the night before we launched
and we had we had left our jobs at aura
TV
we left our salaries and insurance and
the whole thing I said to David and Amir
I was like look this thing could go bust
tomorrow like maybe we really just
screwed up and I don't think we did but
we shall see and within hours of
launching we realized that we
gonna be okay and the show has grown
exponentially since then we've expanded
the team we just had another hire
actually over the summer which is thanks
to you guys on patreon so we just hired
Helen who is now my assistant and
assistant to the Rubin report and she's
just great and I'm sure you guys will
meet her at some point as well and and
we're still looking to expand beyond
that with some graphics people and some
other things so the show has just grown
and grown and grown and I'm really proud
of what we've built and what we realized
though was we wanted to clean up patreon
because we were in so early that we did
some things that maybe we wanted to do
differently you guys know I do this day
I do an 8:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. day once
a month where I do these one on mostly
one-on-one chats with people who are the
very high tier people and we realized
that because I'm on tour with Jordan
Peterson now and this is basically we're
rolling into 2019 on this I'm about to
do another like 50 stops with him 16 in
Europe which is all on Dave Rubin calm I
don't think the European stuff actually
is there yet because we're finalizing I
might miss one or two in the middle but
we've got all our dates on there and
stand-up dates and all that but the
point is we're expanding we're building
everything we're doing and we felt that
I was just I didn't have as much time to
do the one-on-ones and we wanted to
change the tiers so in many cases if you
are on patreon and you're one of our
patrons you are now getting more for
less we're going to try to make the live
streams and the AMA is this kind of
thing a little bit bigger and more
engaging but also one of the things that
I really realized when when we were off
the grid was that look everyone looked
the Internet's great social media it's
all good you know we can complain about
it all the time and obviously we all
have issues with it and people are
seemingly acting crazy and behaviors
online or leaking into real life and
okay all that stuff but I do think that
overall the the conversations that are
happening this is a net good I still
think it's a net good but the trolls and
the haters not even the trolls as much
but just like haters and just all that
stuff are just ransacking everything
they're just like going through and
destroying everything so our feeling was
if we can build some real community on
patreon where for you know a couple
bucks you can get in and you know we
post all our videos there you can chat
with people who you might agree with my
disagree with but do it in somewhat of a
Praful manner and if you won't do that
we'll just return your money and that's
it we thought it would be a cool thing
to do so that's why we launched Rubin
select and we posted a video this
morning all about that so you know since
we launched originally on patreon as I
said back and I think June of 2016 we
really haven't done I think maybe one
other time we did a real push for it but
we do want people to know about it today
because by being on patreon you guys
have allowed me to say no I said no to
at least three networks in the last
three in the last year that wanted me to
join and be part of things I've said no
to bigger money offers a whole series of
other things because I'm controlling
what we do here and we've got a great
small business and as that as I said
we're expanding and that really is
because of you guys
so here's what I do so anyone if you go
to patreon.com slash rubin report right
now anyone that donates any amount will
get a live shout-out on the stream right
now I've got a handy iPad here with all
sorts of questions and a bunch of other
things so Reuben report comm slash
patreon and donate any amount right
there and you're gonna get a live shout
out and then we are going to oh I'm
sorry it's not any amount it's level 1
or above you'll understand it when you
get there level 1 or above I'm gonna
give you a shout out if I did any amount
it would be completely insane I'd be
screaming my head off all for the next
five hours so or if you increase up to
level one and then let's just see I want
to get this all straight okay if you
join level 5 or above while I am live
right now I will Skype with you as a
thank you after this show that's right
I'm devoting the whole day to it today
and then I head back out on the road so
if you donate to level 5 or above you're
gonna get a Skype one-on-one video thank
you from me to day I promise you that
couple just came in John and Ben thank
you very much and if you so level 1
you're gonna get a verbal shout-out
level 2 okay why am I wearing this shirt
so this was our original patreon
exclusive t-shirt so only people who are
at that the the t-shirt level of patreon
for the last two years have this shirt
it's kind of fun because I see it out in
the Petersons crowd sometimes people
have worn it
to to stand-up shows and wherever else
I've seen one or two on the street I saw
one at the mall the other day so if you
donate but we're not using these shirts
anymore because now our new patreon
shirts are Ruben select shirts so these
are the old shirts we've got a bunch
left over so there's a limited amount
cuz we're not going to be printing any
more of them so if you donate now while
I am live at level or level two or above
you are gonna get the original Ruben
report patreon t-shirt that's right
we're gonna send that to you and the
select members are getting the new
t-shirt that's at a at a higher level
shout-out to Jack okay alright so I want
to make this a little bit about that
kind of fundraising and talking about
that but I also want to answer your
questions I know you guys have a lot of
questions about about the off-the-grid
thing and just catching up on everything
and everything else so let's go let's
just start doing some stuff and I'm
gonna go to patreon first though I will
jump in on super chat as well when is
Kanye West coming on the show I am
pretty sure it's gonna happen like just
give me a little time on it it's one of
these things that's out there in the
universe this guy operates in the
universe we're gonna make it happen at
some point yo Dave where do you get your
shirts your dress shirts I think they're
awesome
so most of my dress shirts I'm hesitant
to say it because then everyone's gonna
start wearing them and then it won't
look as cool but most of my dress shirts
are Ted Baker which you there are Ted
Baker stores I think they're in
Nordstrom or Bloomingdale's but I've got
about five of those on rotation that I
that I really do dig and I know people
really like them but please don't wear
them all over the place because then
then it won't be special anymore and
that's obviously very important Rueben
always seems to come back on the grid
around my birthday 9/5 happy birthday to
you please interview Michael knows I'd
be happy that Michael on the show I
think there was some discussion about it
before I got off the grid we'll make it
happen
we've got some great shows coming up by
the way we've already booked out
basically through October because of my
troubles are so crazy we had to get
ahead of the 8-ball here our guest next
week probably is the biggest get we've
ever had we've been in the works on this
thing for gosh eight months or so we
were supposed to have this person on in
May
then there was a little hiccup but next
week it's probably our biggest get yet
and I think sort of what will be viewed
as a game-changing interview so I'm
super psyched about that as I said I
head to Rochester tomorrow then Long
Island and Connecticut then I come home
for that interview then I head out to
four different cities in Florida with
Peterson then I actually have a couple
days at my parents house then I'm down
in Grand Rapids we're all over the place
so a lot lots happened and lots
happening here remember you're gonna get
a shout out if you join a level two or
above you're gonna get a shout out right
now like Jonathan you just got a shout
out my friend thank you very much and if
you jump in at level five or above
you're gonna get a Skype thank you from
me right now and by the way the whole
point of creating reuben select as i
said not only do i want to create
community there where you can actually
chat and engage with and respond to
people without just the endless noise
look that things always going to exist
look this is the beauty this is the
catch-22 of the internet right we we put
all of these things out there or I don't
know we put them out there all of these
things got out there Twitter Facebook
MySpace
Friendster all of these social media
things and we never knew exactly what we
were doing and we started being friends
with our co-workers and then you know
connecting with someone from 20 years
ago who then you were never going to
connect with again after one connection
and all of these things and it just
became this like giant cacophony of
craziness and I know how many of you
care about these issues that we talked
about on the show just as much as I do
and I think by creating a little home a
little space for that and by throwing a
couple bucks in its going to eliminate
99% of the haters I mean that's the
irony the the ante to get in the game is
so low because you can create a zillion
burner accounts on Twitter and just a
million anonymous accounts and the bots
have been ramped up and all of that
stuff that is ruining a lot of the
goodness and it's making good people
crazy so I really wanted to try to
create or at least foster an atmosphere
where people would be able to have good
conversations and my guys will be in
there furthering the conversations I'm
gonna jump in you know when I'm on the
plane and I have time and I'll be
checking in with you guys and responding
and all that good stuff
and so the level 5 tier that we have on
Rubin select now
the Google hangout so I used to be doing
all these one-on-ones and a couple
groups we've expanded the group Google
Hangouts to a bunch of them I think
there are a hundred slots total and we
do groups of 20 and then groups of 10
and groups of 5 depending on how much
you donate and I have to tell you they
have been amazing I mean the the last
two years that I've been able to once a
month talk to a group of you guys from
all over the world sometimes I'm talking
to people from Australia and Mexico and
Japan and Brazil all in one group and
people have gotten to know each other
it's also helped me frame some of my
ideas because when you talk to people
all over the world and they're every
gender and sexuality and religion and
all that and you go wow we're all kind
of thinking about the same stuff it
really makes you see how actually small
the world is and and and that we can all
care or be concerned about the same
things it's pretty great Molly welcome
aboard thank you very much Michael how
you doing my friend all right let's see
do you see any viable way back to
civility for a political party that is
called the other side and it's 30
percent of voters Nazis so Ben and I
touched on this a little bit earlier
it's gonna be tough man there's a fly in
here a fly has made its way into the new
Rueben report set it's going to be very
tough if your if your strategy and your
go-to move is always to say that the
other people do this because they're
racist it's hard to back out of that
right and this is where the Democrats
find themselves it seems pretty clear to
me after talking to Ben that there was
no backing away from that that if
anything it's just gotten worse so I
don't know how much worse it has to get
I mean this is this is the million
dollar question how much worse does this
sort of collectivist leftist
monster have to get before it implodes
now look it could implode if they do
really badly in the midterms it could
start imploding but I don't want to talk
about this only through in American lens
because this isn't it only an American
phenomena I'm getting I'm getting
messages from all sorts of people all
over the world that are dealing with
this in their own countries Mexico for
example just voted in a very left
government so I don't know how you do it
how do you how do you call someone a
Nazi forever and then finally you wake
up and you go
well I guess you're not a Nazi I'm just
an then you got to really turn
the lens on yourself which is which is a
tough one but I do know this that for
the last couple months I've been on this
tour with Peterson I've done all sorts
of speaking events I've been back on
tour doing stand-up we've sold out every
single show that I've done and I am
meeting thousands and thousands of great
people out there and people who agree
and disagree and I'll have it one of the
shows we were in Seattle I brought Eric
Weinstein on so what I tried to do at
the stand-up shows is I usually do about
an hour a stand-up and then I bring on
one of the IDW guys so I've brought on
Eric Weinstein I brought on Brett Wine
Santa brought on christina hoff sommers
we have a special guest coming to the
show in Salt Lake City and a whole bunch
of others but in the audience I had
there was a there was a black Magga hat
wearing Trump supporter and I'm only
mentioning his race because people seem
to if you look at the world through this
lens then this is important and this
white guy who happened to have a shaved
head so basically look like a skinhead
and he was he was a liberal right so
these people were flipping the script
and we kind of got into it and I was
playing with both him in the car they
got up in the middle of show and hugged
so I'm telling you there are great
things happening out there and the media
doesn't want you to see it because they
want to keep you in this endless fight
machine and just this hate machine and
all this other stuff but don't don't
fall for it just don't fall for it guys
all right quick shout outs to jeremy
thomas noah ian jacob chevy and beth
great names people all very short names
a lot of one in two syllable people
right there okay we're gonna need some
buy spray in here I'm being attacked
over here okay here we go I'm gonna jump
back into patreon is there any chance of
an IDW summit in the future to bring
together all the thinkers everyone has
come to be drawn to while you guys
collaborate very frequently and
everyone's schedules are packed it would
be very exciting to bring together this
group with their diverse fan bases for a
large forum discussion I can't say too
much on this but there are a lot of
discussions about that
there are discussions not among not only
amongst ourselves but amongst a lot of
representation we're trying to figure it
out so also you got to remember Jordan
and I are now on tour basically through
the rest of 2018 and then we're going I
think to Australia in 20 and February of
2019 and then maybe one or two I think
it's gonna end officially in March Sam's
doing live shows again Ben just did a
couple live shows so there's like a
tremendous amount to coordinate the
beauty of this thing is we know it's all
working every single one of us that is
doing this stuff is working and people
are coming out and and spending their
hard-earned money to listen to people
talk about ideas and as I said before
the shows with Jordan and I those are
the ones that I'm most familiar with
obviously they they've just been a true
joy I mean they've been a true joy a
couple protestors here and there and I
kind of walked out and I've talked to
some of the protesters and whatever but
we have to just coordinate a massive
bunch of stuff and also figure out what
do we all want you know we all want and
need different things some of us have
shows some of us are academics who are
now caught on the outside of that brett
weinstein and heather hiding for example
you know somebody like eric weinstein
who's been sort of the the architect of
this whole thing the guy's got a job he
works at teal capital so we're trying to
figure out how to figure out all of this
and get all the parts right and you know
one thing I can tell you for sure is
there isn't a lot of ego management I
know you'd think that maybe with all
these these big names and fan bases or
whatever that you'd have like a lot of
that kind of stuff there really hasn't
been any of that we're trying to figure
it out I know a bunch you saw that
picture when a bunch of us Rogen
Peterson Sam Ben Eric me went out to
dinner it's like we just had a freaking
great time and we barely talked about
politics we talked about psychedelics
more than we talked about politics so
trust me we're working about on all
these things
all right reminder level-one if you go
to rubin report comm slash patreon right
now or Dave Rubin calm slash donate
you're gonna get a verbal shout out if
you jump in at level one or above level
tor above we're gonna send you the
original Rubin report patreon t-shirt
we've only got limited amounts to the
left we are not making them anymore
because they're gonna be Rubin select
t-shirts right now so this t-shirt that
I'm wearing can be yours people level
fiver above the
Skype you right after this we're gonna
shut down and I'll Skype you as a
personal thank you I would gladly say
hello we can talk one-on-one for a
couple minutes happy to do that Steve
welcome aboard thank you very much
what else did I want to tell you all
right let's jump into questions for a
second
super chat love the new set keep up the
good discussions that is the plan hey
Dave I'm gonna be at the Connecticut 12
rules for life event I was wondering if
you're gonna be opening or be part of
that event thanks so much love the show
a lot keep up the good work I will be
there so I open up the show I do about
10 or 15 minutes to stand-up I get
everybody going and screaming and
laughing Jordan comes on he does about
an hour and a half as I've said before
it's different every night it's it's
it's been a true joy to watch and it's
humbling as for somebody like me
because it's like man this guy changes
it up he explores where his intellect
wants to go I can see him weaving in and
out of ideas and kind of pushing an idea
further one night and then really jumpin
the next night the Q&A is then I jump
back in he does the hour and a half I
jump back in for about a half hour 45
minutes of Q&A where I take some
audience questions and that's to me
that's my favorite part and I actually
think the audience probably likes it the
most because Jordan I get to play around
I get to make them laugh make the
audience after the audience love seeing
the guy laugh so you're gonna absolutely
have a ball so look forward to that by
the way if you've pledged at the level 5
tier or above email contact at Rubin
report comm with your skype name so that
we know we can grab you on skype after
this actually if you've pledged any
other things so if you've pledged and I
need your skype name or if your pledge
and we need your shirt size and mailing
address and all that contact at Rubin
report com Kevin how you doing man thank
you very much welcome aboard welcome
back Dave where did that red chair run
off to ok so we have all this so we were
trying to figure out what to do so it
was it was a crazy month of doing all
this like even though we were off the
grid we we busted our asses special
shout out to Amira who coordinated all
of this David and I were away for a
little bit and there was just like boxes
being delivered every day and things
being moved and you know it all looks so
easy like when you guys see it but it
really wasn't so basically the entire
set then got moved into our control room
and it was just stacked up and you
couldn't move anywhere so we're trying
to figure out what to do with all the
stuff because
is you know part of me is like you know
we should I don't know what to do like I
wanted to put some of it in my house
like I like the stuff I know a lot of
people would want the red chair you know
we have two of the green chairs where
the guests at we've got the artwork that
was behind me we've got the artwork that
was behind the guests I think that maybe
we're just gonna just offer it to the
highest bidder or not even to the
highest bidder you know what this is
what we'll do for now let's just see if
some that happens here I have no idea
and I'm just doing this off the top of
my head if you if you want to make an
offer on any of this stuff just email us
with what you want to offer we've got
the red chair we've got the old table by
the way we've got the chairs we've got
some artwork pick something that was on
the old set make us an offer if you
don't have a lot of money make a case
why we should just send you something I
don't know let's just see what happens
let's just see what happens and maybe
we'll send you guys some stuff I can't
make any promises yeah let me just see
what kind of response we get on that but
that sounds something like that sounds
nice let's see Shh thoughts on the war
on in and out and thought on Eric
Bauman's call for a boycott on the
burger chain literally as we were having
lunch just now David said something
about the war on in and out I'm a little
unclear they donated some money someone
and in and out donated some money to a
conservative cause I will be very clear
on this I don't know the exact details
of the story yet in and out is delicious
I get it animal style and now because
I'm doing the paleo thing I do protein
style which is no bun you just get it on
a lettuce wrap it is absolutely
delicious and much like chick-fil-a I'm
not going to stop eating it eating it
because some hysterical person doesn't
want me to eat it so that's all I could
say about that
Keegan welcome aboard Dave welcome
aboard Sean welcome aboard thank you
guys appreciate the support and remember
when you're jumping in at that level one
or above you now have access to all of
our videos in the patreon feed so if
you're sick of what's going on on the
YouTube comments section or just
fighting with people on Twitter if you
spend a little more time there or me and
my team will be in there but more
importantly than us you'll be able to
interact with some other people who
actually want to engage in these ideas
and I know that friendships have been
formed over these things when we've done
the
hangout things I've now I've become
friends with some of these people also
some of the one-on-one people and the
group people but I've been to dinner
with some people we've done some
business deals with some people I know
people have done other business deals
with other people so we can actually
create a secondary I'm not trying to
replace Twitter I'm not trying to build
a new internet or any of that but I
think we can create a little bit of a
home for some cool people who actually
want to engage ideas and be respectful
and also meet other like-minded people I
think that's what we can create so it's
pretty cool Brian welcome aboard Josh
welcome aboard
thank you guys remember level 5 or above
I'm gonna Skype with you right after
this thing level 2 or above you're gonna
get the last few patreon shirts they're
all being switched to Reubens select
after this we got a couple more left and
you're gonna get did you see that I just
whack that fly like mr. Miyagi over here
get me some chopsticks guys all right
here we go
thoughts on the loss of austin peterson
did he lose he lost so I didn't even
know that like one of the only
politicians I like trumped endorsed
Republican a name only Josh Holley also
thoughts on Larry shop libertarians in
lost cause districts so first off I
didn't know that I didn't I guess I
didn't even know that that election I
guess it was the primary what was that
what election was it was the Republic
know I guess yeah I guess it was the
Republican primary and Trump endorsed
this other guy Holly that's a shame I
really like Austin we have a couple
disagreements but I think he's a decent
guy who's in it for the right reasons
and and you haven't seen the last time I
promise you that
Larry sharp I had on the show about two
months ago really like the guy
libertarian running for governor of New
York
I think he's got big ideas I think he's
he's pretty fearless he's a good
advocate for the ideas of libertarianism
and limited government so I hope he gets
a good showing you know the second part
your question was about libertarians in
lost cause districts you know nothing's
always a lost cause and I know that
argument there's always this argument
that I now see more from the right but
it flips every now and again so for
example I tell you like it flipped like
there used to be an argument that Ralph
Nader would
her Democrats more because he was going
to get more votes from Al Gore than he
would have got from George W Bush and
that probably was true but now that is
flipped where it's like generally
speaking libertarians which is the only
viable potential third party thing at
the moment far more than the Green Party
they're gonna siphon off more votes from
Republicans than Democrats which
Republicans then are like whoa whoa whoa
forget the third party because we don't
want to risk it
I know that's that's a short-term
strategy that I understand but if you
really want to change ideas over time
you need to start getting some of these
people involved so I don't know that
look we're not getting a libertarian or
even a more classical liberal
presidential candidate certainly from
the Democrats in the next you know four
eight years but what you can do is you
can start flipping little districts
probably more so in the middle of the
country where libertarian ideas I think
have a better route than say in big
cities you could start flipping some of
those and getting some more of those
ideas out there I mean look why is this
show working why do I get the amount of
hate that I get it's because I've given
a little room for these ideas to to grow
so so it's pretty awesome yon welcome
aboard at the level 1 level thank you
very much my friend
at the level 2 level you're gonna get a
Rubin report t-shirt a limited edition
because they ain't being printed anymore
and level 5 and above I'm gonna Skype
with you right after this thing okay
let's see I got the meet and greet for
Jordan Peterson in Westbury will you be
at that meet and greet as well so first
off I'm super psyched for this show it's
on September 6 that's my my home towel
long Islands out of town but I grew up
in Long Island I'm from Long Island I
love Long Island grew up a couple towns
over actually I will be at the show so
the meet agreed situation so this is
what they do at these you pay a little
bit extra I don't know the number
offhand and you can meet Jordan he does
a private talk it's often for about 30
or 40 people he answers a couple extra
questions you get a picture with him an
autograph I was just going for this last
three months I would just go out into
the crowd after and I'd talk to as many
people as possible and it was all good
my guys and the promoters my agents and
the promoters said it was just too much
of a mess to have me doing that
and also because I'm I generally like to
stay as late as everyone will make you
know I don't want anyone to walk out
there and be like Oh Ruben didn't say hi
to me and all that so I'd be hanging
around for a long time so we're actually
doing a separate meet-and-greet for me
so my meet-and-greet will be first then
Jordan some people are gonna go to both
some people are gonna go to some I don't
know the website off the top of my head
I think it's oMG VIP dot-com / Dave -
Ruben something like that close enough
huh / neighbor but oMG VIP comm / Dave
Rubin and you can buy tickets to the
meet-and-greet for me I'll hang out and
I'll sign autographs and take selfies
and all that good stuff and usually
Jordan ice did we stay as long as we
possibly can so we didn't we haven't
even really started promoting that yet
cuz I've been off the grid but I'd love
to meet you in Westbury if you want to
come on come on down patreon do you
consider Maajid Nawaz and Douglas Marie
as part of the IDW why as I've said from
the beginning I don't know that it's for
me specifically certainly but I don't
know that I don't know who it's for to
say who is really part of this amorphous
thing but I certainly would consider
those two of them both of those guys
part of it look I think one of the
things that you have to have if you're
in this is you have to have been a
willingness to have difficult
conversations mojit is absolutely having
that about reforming his own religion
Douglas is certainly having that when it
comes to dealing with immigration
specifically but a slew of other issues
for Douglas as well I think you also
have to be tried by fire a little bit
those guys have been through the hate
machine I think that for whatever the
differences are you know Douglass's is a
gay conservative maajid is a liberal
Muslim again all these label things like
we've we've put a pretty diverse group
of people here together I love both of
those guys we had a wonderful dinner at
Douglass's house with this partner and
and Jordan and his wife and and Majid
and his wife just a great dinner in
London while back so these are good
people where is Emma
you know I tweeted out a picture of Emma
14 years old greatest dog alive that we
were gonna be in here and she left right
before we started so if you want to send
her in feel free but you know she's an
old time right now Marusya thank you
very much welcome aboard to patreon oh
by the way
please if you're watching this and you
dig what we do here please click the
little bell on YouTube and make sure
you're getting all notifications I am
still getting a slew of people telling
me they're not getting our notifications
that our videos never show up in their
feed YouTube keeps telling me basically
that you people are idiots and you don't
know how to subscribe we used to have a
personal contact at YouTube then that
person said no I'm not gonna do this
anymore basically I'm moving on to other
things they didn't give us another
person to talk to they just gave us the
forum whatever it is what it is with
YouTube but please make sure
notifications are on or I know people go
weeks without seeing it or people still
get unsubscribed we looked at our
subscription thing today and it's like
it jumps and then it lowers and it jumps
and it lowers going to keep growing but
we know it should be growing a lot
faster that is although it's growing
quite fast one other thing on patreon by
on YouTube by the way I just found out
this this morning so that we posted I
feel well I think what were pretty some
pretty great shows while we were gone we
posted
Kolia noir we posted Kathryn Birbal
saying we posted Jeffrey Tucker and we
posted who was the other person oh and
dr. Deborah so a pretty interesting
diverse group of people the Deborah so
full episode now she's a sex researcher
and we had a long ranging conversation
on gender and equality and a series of
things that got D monetized you know I
think it has a couple hundred thousand
views a Bacchae D monetized so that's
the type of thing that's exactly why
we're on patreon if we were relying on
the on the YouTube money even when it
suddenly gets better and they monetize
things for all you just don't know what
the hell is gonna happen here so patreon
is our way of sort of safely funding
these things so that I'm relying on you
guys which I guess ultimately that's not
relying either like anyone can come and
go as they please that's fine but at
least we're not only reliant on that so
yeah still giving verbal shoutouts
welcome aboard Sean thank you very much
let's see can the importance of
protecting the values of Western
civilization be overstated no I don't
think they can I think we don't talk
about them enough and we don't explain
why the values of Western civilization
free speech and open inquiry open
inquiry and an education secular
education and and not giving too much
power to any one person or government
these things have all been huge parts of
Western civilization these are the the
cornerstones of what I think will give
the opportunity for the most people to
be free the spring can fly I need those
chopsticks guys so I think we need to do
a better cell job some reason the West
almost seems to be suffering from its
own success where it's like something
becomes so successful but then it breeds
sort of a next generation of people who
hate it because they don't know what
real suffering is so when you hear all
of these young people at colleges now
who are you know they're literally at
colleges you know wearing designer stuff
all walking around with iPhones and
Nikes and all of this stuff telling you
how oppressed they are they have no
freaking idea what oppression is you
know it ain't you're not oppressed for
being gay in this country you're not
oppressed for being black in this
country you're not oppressed for being
any minority we have welcomed more of
all of these people to this place to
make a better life for themselves and in
almost every case it's worked and if you
don't believe me think about your
grandparents right now you person
watching this okay pause for a moment
think about your grandparents here I'll
think about mine okay do you have it
better or worse than them and in almost
every single case you're gonna have it
better and that is pretty freakin great
and on top of all of the studies by a
book that I have right over here that
Steven Pinker has written about it's
called enlightenment now talking about
all of the trends that are better
positive in the world where there is
less mass violence in genocide and
there's more trees being planted and all
sorts of other things but it's very easy
if you always go to the fear center of
the brain you can get people believing
all sorts of horrible things and that
the wheels are coming off all the time
and that Western civilization is evil it
doesn't mean it's perfect but nothing's
perfect and the people who think they
can eat engineer perfection almost
always are the people who engineer some
horrible horrible things okay
let's go how much money did you lose
when a video is demonetised it's almost
impossible to say because a it depends
obviously on the video views what I can
tell you is this and this is this is
rough and if one of my guys want to
correct me but YouTube basically pays
out a $2 CPM so that's basically we get
$2 per thousand views I can't remember
off the top of my head if that's before
they are 55% cut or after but I think
it's about $2 per thousand views so
that's pretty much it so then you can
extrapolate numbers after that point so
it really depends but it also now I
think has to do with watch time and a
series of other factors so in a case
like the Deborah so one where I know I
last I saw I definitely had at least
120,000 views or something like that and
it probably has more now and it probably
had a great watch time right because we
I think we did about an hour or so and
it was a really engaging conversation
and the watch times on this channel are
extremely good our watch times last
month last I saw was something around 20
minutes of video that's almost unheard
of on YouTube right people watch things
for two seconds and click away so you do
get some benefits related to things like
that for putting up quality content that
people are actually watching and
engaging with so a video like that I'm
not gonna do all the math in my head but
we definitely lost a couple hundred
bucks maybe a thousand bucks on
something like that and again YouTube
can do whatever it wants and it's on us
as I discussed with Ben earlier to
figure out if there's some alternatives
I know there's a lot of discussions
being had about that stuff but as we
figure all that out another way if you
if you care about this stuff join us on
Ruben select and there's a bunch of
different tiers and depending on what
you want by the way you can get so this
is the old Ruben report sure you there's
a new Ruben report sure we got Ruben
report mugs I autograph some stuff we
got the one-on-one hangouts well no we
don't have the one I know it's anymore
man we've got the group hangouts which
we've expanded to now 100 slots we've
got some behind the scenes stuff we're
gonna do some more live AMAs a whole
bunch of other stuff like that alright
let me do a little a little radio reset
for you guys right here so I'm doing a
little AMA back on the grid it's good to
be back and nice to talk to you guys
again I so far I've stayed away from
from all that whatever hate maybe come
in my way I'm not really paying
attention to I'm just having a good day
here with my team and
doing the livestream abandoned with you
guys but what we are doing here is I
wanted to tell you guys about Reuben
select which is our new patreon program
so you go to patreon.com/crashcourse of
different rewards and right now if you
donate at level 2 or above we're gonna
send you this t-shirt level 1 or above
I'm gonna give you a verbal shout out
right now and level 5 or above I'm gonna
Skype with you right after this or if
you're a current patreon and you just
move up to one of those levels we're
good to go all right let's see this is a
good one on super chat imagine Trump
didn't happen what are your criteria for
electing the next president in 2024 are
you leaning more liberal conservative or
hopeful that liberal libertarians will
pose a serious threat to the
establishment here's what I would love
to see let's just not even Trump doesn't
even have to be part of this discussion
for a second what I would love to see
and what I think will happen post Trump
whether it's post Trump in in two years
or if he gets a second term is I think
that the bulk of people who are still
quiet now because they're sort of afraid
of being yelled at and they're afraid of
the mob and they're afraid of being
attacked and all of those things I think
most of these people are waking up and
they're and most of us are these people
we're good decent people we disagree on
some stuff we we feel you know everyone
feels like everything is the worst it's
the worst it's ever been and in the
political tenor is the worst it's ever
been and it can't get worse we're not
killing each other over politics yet it
can get a lot worse let's stop it from
getting there but what I think will
happen is the outrage machine on both
sides will eventually start crushing
itself and I think we're seeing that on
the left at the moment it'll start
crushing itself and there will be an
avenue for some decency so what I would
love to see this is the best situation
then I'll tell you what I what I think I
would go for the best situation I think
would be for a truly principled
conservative to run against a truly
principled liberal what you would have
by that is you could have a real limited
government conservative who may be
conservative on things like abortion
and you know would be for death penalty
and a bunch of other things versus a
liberal I mean an old-school liberal so
I would say someone more from the
classical liberal family who believes in
there's some sense of limited government
but that the government when done right
can do good things again this is where I
talk about why I still consider myself a
liberal instead of a libertarian but I'm
always happy to have that conversation
and I get it I'm very intrigued I love
talking to libertarians and the and caps
about how to disassemble the whole
freaking thing I think that's a really
fun intellectual exercise where do you
draw that line where is it a point where
you absolutely need the government
that's an interesting intellectual
exercise I think there is a chance that
we will have lanes for some decent
people to come out of what feels like a
real sort of crazy mess right now I
would love to have that debate and I
think we will get there I actually do if
we don't just tear ourselves apart which
I don't think we're gonna do I know
that's counter to what almost everyone
is saying but I really think we can get
to a place where having a real fight
over these ideas a real fight over
policy why is the death penalty right or
wrong why is why is abortion right or
wrong or why is it in the federal
government's interest to even have an
make it an issue roe v wade as a federal
issue versus state issue all of these
things whatever side you're on
we should be allowed to talk about these
things and that's why it's very cool I
think when we look at the amount of
people that are watching this show
watching Shapiro listening to Sam
watching or listening to Rogen it's like
there is a massive group of people
growing and growing and growing that are
okay hearing different ideas that are
okay watching people debate ideas and
argue over things and not hate each
other and I think as these people and
they're mostly young right now as they
gain more power and they gain more
influence and they have more of the
influential jobs maybe in mainstream I
think some good things are gonna happen
so I'm very hopeful for that do I think
ultimately a libertarian could pose a
threat to the establishment I think of
court well of course the answer is yes
right like if you gave me the greatest
most charismatic really principled well
thought-out libertarian I think those
ideas really could win out the day in in
many many cases especially now where
there's such tumult politically Gary
Johnson obviously was not that guy and I
hate throwing the guy under the bus
because I think he's a decent human
being so I'm not throwing him under the
bus just saying I don't think he was
that guy but if there was a really
really clever smart energetic photogenic
you know libertarian no I'm not gonna do
it by the way people out there I think
that that would pose a real threat and
again it's like you know it's always
people always say well do you we wanna
we want a revolution Bernie I want a
political revolution and it's like you
know a revolution you guys a political
revolution because it sounds nicer but
the more these people talk about
revolutions think about it if you live
in America right now do you want a
revolution is it that bad that you want
a revolution probably not it doesn't
mean we can't make it better but it the
the way we talk about these things is
very dangerous this is still a freaking
good place and I'm gonna keep fighting
to to make it better all right let's
jump back to or give a couple shoutouts
here Stephen Ryan max welcome aboard
guys level 1 or above you're gonna get a
verbal shout out level 2 or above the
last few original patreon Rubin report
shirts because we're going to Rubin
select shirts after this and level 5 or
above I'm gonna Skype with you right
after patreon.com slash Rubin report and
Rubin report.com slash donate and
remember the wider idea here is not only
are you funding this show but I promise
you once you download that patreon app
and look what's going on and feed there
and see those conversations
they'll be conversations that you want
to be part of and it doesn't matter if
you're anonymous or using your real name
as long as you're doing it kind of
respectfully and decently and by the way
if a massive amount of trolls decide to
suddenly pay me to ransack the place
well we'll just boot them I don't want
their money so it's a exercising I guess
a little bit of control over over the
the big thing the big monster that the
Internet has come if you've joined at
any level by the way and we're gonna
send you a t-shirt or if we're gonna do
a Skype with you or anything
email us contact at Rubin report.com and
as long as I'm talking about that
somebody asked before about the set if
you want any of the old set stuff we're
still trying to figure it out what to do
make me your best offer make us a pitch
either a financial pinch or I don't know
whatever the hell you would tell me
something tell me something fun contact
at Rubin report comm I doubt we're gonna
part with the red chair because I think
we're keeping that for when I do bigger
panels but we've got the two guest
chairs we've got the table we've got
some artwork and a bunch of other stuff
I don't know make an offer let's make
make me an offer I can't refuse you know
what I'm saying okay here we go
doot doot doot doot doot do you think
all leftist agenda and I mean black
lives matter or me too or Europe
immigration is controlled centrally it
can be something more than stupid people
talking about equality I think you mean
can't I don't know I got into this a
little bit with men like all of these
things these days it's like you know
these Twitter campaigns to attack people
and all these anonymous accounts that
kind of look the same and use the same
language and it's like is there some
central controlling of this and it's
look I'll go down a conspiracy theory
I'm happy to do that but as Carl Sagan
said and as I quote often extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence so
I would need some actual evidence to see
that there are really coordinated
centralized campaigns on all of these
things I think there are some high-level
talks about all of this so there's no
doubt that the the BLM people are
talking to the me to people and are
talking to these people and that people
and that there's a coordination of all
of this stuff at some level but I don't
know that it all trickles down it's hard
to it's hard to really understand I
guess that's a little bit part of the
problem but it's also weird how it seems
to be happening in all these countries
all at the same time you know
fortunately I think you know America has
one great leg up on the rest of the
world which is our First Amendment our
right to free speech and not to say
other countries don't have free speech
but it is so enshrined as the First
Amendment the most important thing you
can have is our ability to express
ourselves and as long as we have that
and the government doesn't take that
away we can fight these bad forces it's
what I'm doing every day and I suspect
many of you are doing in your life shout
out to James and shout out to Luke
welcome aboard
all right let's see Dave how's your
gaming hobby with Colin going what are
you enjoying will you be streaming on
Twitch with friends so we've we've
thought about maybe doing a twitch thing
or a little more with video games in
general I think maybe I would do
something like that just purely purely
for fun as I've been traveling I haven't
had as much time to be jumping in I do
have a Nintendo switch because one of
you guys sent me one and I've taken that
on the road a little bit but I'm also
trying to write I'm trying to read I'm
also occasionally trying to catch up on
some sleep
so like I'm a little bit like sort of
between things my brother visited for a
week and we played a ton of NBA LIVE we
were playing I was the 91 Trail Blazers
he was usually the 86 Celtics we split a
couple games played played some Mario
Kart with my nephew
we played what's that game that
everybody was telling me to get not
Smash Brothers the game it's sort of
like contra on ps4 you blow up a whole
bunch of with 80s video game
carries movies characters busts bang
bust bust but not bang bus that's
something else
Bob somebody help me with this someone
will throw it in the comment section
you're a bunt you compete like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and then Sylvester
Stallone and all these guys and Chuck
Norris and you're blowing stuff up and
boom bust bust bang boom something or
something let's see
all right I'll move on but somebody get
me that would ya let's see have any of
the commenters you've hosted informed or
deeply impacted your beliefs well look
I've certainly been influenced by people
and I try to keep an open mind and
really hear people I really do I think
you most of you guys know that that
first time I had Larry elder on when we
were discussing systemic racism and he
just beat me into a pulp I think you
know that that was one of my wake up mom
and so obviously Larry has really
affected me I would say this I would say
that being on tour with Jordan it's it's
been a privilege and it's been a
life-changing thing I mean look this is
this guy is probably the top public
intellectual we have in the world right
now I don't think I'm exaggerating when
I say that the most influential at least
and as we go from sold-out city to
sold-out City and I watch him as I said
before explore his own intellect
challenge his own beliefs you know go
away for
week so he could do these couple events
with sam harris where they went at it
intellectually and then see how that
changes the way jordan talks about this
or that and does it all respectfully and
how also he survived the hate machine
and the awful articles and all of that
if anything they've all made him
stronger i would say he's moved me a
little bit on you know i've oh I think
I've always understood the archetypal
stuff and the need for stories and
things like that he does bring it back
to why he thinks the West basically
needs those stories through a religious
prism to survive what what's going on
right now I think that's that's a really
interesting point that I've been
thinking a lot about I thought about it
a lot actually when I was away
so these guys have all influenced me in
different ways you know Eric Weinstein
not only brilliant mind on economics and
math and all that but there's such an
empathy there is a human that I think
I've taken some of that in look I get to
sit with great incredible people that
not only do I get to interview but many
of whom have now become my friend
the it's awesome it's great and if you
weren't affected by these people you
know I said this at the end of the last
show with Jordan before we took the
break I was like you know it's you guys
get to come here and be with him for two
hours and experience this and I know how
important it is for you guys well I've
been on tour with the guy for months and
and you know we have private time in the
in the green room before and we talked
about some of the things that were
struggling with or thinking about or
whatever it is and it's like man if you
don't change after you do something like
that I don't know what we change you so
the best I think I can do is keep keep
exploring my own thoughts keep seeing
where where the truth takes me all right
Ruben report.com / donate we now are
Ruben select where we're building a
really great community I'd love to get
that number I'm not worried about the
financial number what I would love to do
is I think we have about 4,700 patrons
I'd love to get that 2 to 5,000 in
pretty short order really help build out
that community over there and I think
you guys will really dig what's going on
over there we have a special feed so
basically if you go to level 1 if you go
to the $5 a month tier you'll have
access to all of the bid every video we
post on youtube you'll have access to in
the patreon feed and then you'll be able
to interact with some more like-minded
people without all the all the craziness
if you go to level 1 or above I'm gonna
give you a verbal shoutout right now
level 2 or above you're gonna get
t-shirt the classic as we call it Reuben
report t-shirt that is no longer being
produced and level 5 or above we're
going to give you a Skype thank you
immediately after the live stream okay
oh the video game people broforce I
don't know what the hell I said bangbus
it was something like that
it's broforce not bangbus okay very good
thoughts on a Reuben report movie night
or Reuben report book club we're
thinking about both of them and we
almost included both both to different
degrees in this new Reuben select tear
thing that we're breaking down but we we
bit off a tremendous amount this summer
as I said we expanded the team with new
hires we build out the new set the new
website Dave Rubin comm just the new
graphics new music it was like a whole
slew of stuff so we didn't feel we could
lay that out and have it done properly
immediately but especially especially I
love the movie night one the book one's
great the movie night I just think maybe
would be a little more fun and is a less
of a lift for people so just a little a
little patience on that I think you guys
know we've been pretty positive we've
been pretty good I should say about you
know following through with the things
that I talked about here so let's see
keep keep believing on us and we'll keep
going patron how do you discuss ideas
without hatefulness turning the topic
negative because I'm losing people I
considered friends over a rational
question okay I'm really glad you asked
this I get asked this all the time
and I want to tell you a little insider
something that happened to me during the
break so I mentioned to you guys that I
had a very good friend lifelong friend
that about a year ago we met at a bar
and he just went on a we hadn't seen
each other in a while but he just went
on a relentless assault about politics
he met you know he's got he's massively
antitrump he's a progressive lefty okay
fine that's no problem I haven't I was
that and I have many friends that are
still lefties and all that but he went
on this what became a very personal
attack to me at one point I paused him
and I said do you think it's possible
that I believe what I believe as much as
you believe
you believe and he looked me straight in
the eye and said no and I thought this
is crazy this is someone I know my
entire life you're attacking my my very
integrity now after that we didn't talk
for about eight months or so he sort of
called me and left sort of a half
apology I actually paid the bill for
both of us and I just walked out of the
bar I've never done anything like that
and I think you guys know this is not
how I conduct conversations right so I
wasn't I wasn't happy with it but we
basically lost contact for about eight
months over these last couple weeks had
this little break here he and his wife
came over for dinner and I in my mind I
was thinking look if if he wants to go
down that route again then even me even
someone who is willing to engage in all
these ideas willing to talk to people I
disagree with but I won't be I won't be
personally insulted or personally
attacked and I made it clear that I was
off the grid anyway so we weren't going
to talk about current events so we
didn't we didn't talk about current
events we didn't get into any of that
stuff we just talked about kids and
basketball and video games and whatever
else there is movies and whatever and
and but my feeling was if it goes down
that route well then I gotta end this
like I don't need a friend in this case
who is just gonna personally attack me
like I'm not I'm a decent human but I'm
not a punching bag and I think that's
how a lot of you guys feel too it's like
you can keep making overtures to try to
explain yourself you can keep saying
well I believe this and this and this
and that's different and then you and
when the person goes well you're racist
and you go well I haven't said anything
racist you can only do that so many
times when you have to have some
self-respect so I think this is a little
bit different for everybody but it's a
it's a really tough one right it's a
really really tough one where do you say
well I cannot do this anymore or I need
a break from this whether it's a friend
or a family member or something else I
think the best thing that you can do is
try consistently to be as human as you
can with them it sort of sounds cliche
like what does that really mean but it's
like try always to really like look at
them get close get close in there look
at them and you
tell me I'm a racist to my face because
I believe in states rights or whatever
the hell it is and it's like their
arguments have become really really thin
and that's why they're so angry all the
time
one other quick thing we had another
couple over here and the the boyfriend
who I'm less friendly with who's again a
big lefty but I'm happy to do our thing
we got into it over politics and and he
was really you know he's coming at me
with a lot of the just general talking
points on the left systemic racism all
of these things and the Republicans are
so mean another and I kept coming back
with good arguments good arguments good
argument and it kept escalating and kept
escalating and there was a moment where
I knew I could go in for the kill and if
I went in for the kill either he was
gonna come around to he was gonna wake
up enough let's say or he was gonna go
crazy like it was not the night would
have been a blowout and because I was on
this break and off the grid and
everything else I just wasn't up for it
so like all right when I had him there I
let it go and we'll continue that
conversation so you got to figure out
what works for you but I know it's not
easy and it doesn't and it doesn't feel
good to turn the other cheek all the
time and some point when you're getting
abused long enough you you got to speak
up for yourself okay people Rueben
report calm slash patreon I want to read
off a couple more your names if you join
in at level one I'm gonna read your name
alright now I've shout out for you it's
also Dave Rubin dot-com / donate if you
jump in at level 1 or above we're gonna
do a verbal shout out for you right here
level 2 or above you're getting this
shirt level 5 or above I'm gonna give
you a Skype thank you right after this
okay you yeah you can go to Reuben
report.com slash donate and figure out
what you want to do over there okay and
also by the way on this on these live
streams that I'm gonna keep doing we're
always going to prioritize the patreon
questions because so many things fly in
that I'm going to give preference to the
people who are the who are the
supporters so to speak let's see
there is no utopia so in systems
designed for societies who is we must
always grade on the curve the United
States is clearly on the top of that
curve for benefits to mankind by a large
margin
is there any country that comes close so
I
basically agree with you here this is
the line about all these people that
want utopia end up bringing us to
dystopia because they think if they can
just manage everything with central
planning and big government that good
people and good things will happen well
it rarely does when you keep giving
power to some centralized thing that's
above you okay so in terms of benefits
to mankind by a large margin
yeah the United States has done more
good yes I know people love to talk
about this or that and have we made
mistakes and gone to wrong wars and all
these as all countries have done
terrible things and if you want to be
part of the international community
you're gonna make mistakes and we're
gonna have presidents that aren't going
to be perfect and who are gonna do
things that one half of the people don't
like them that the other half of the
people don't like and all of these
things but I just fundamentally believe
that the freedoms that we have in the
United States are our freedoms that if
they were everywhere and I'm not saying
we should nation-state enforce these
freedoms on everyone but imagine if
every country in the world if all people
on this earth had the freedoms that you
if you're watching this in the United
States imagine if people everywhere had
the exact freedoms that you have why is
it that when when we've done you know
gigs in London or in Canada or in some
other places people are starting to
become more and more concerned about
free speech because they don't have the
protecting the protections that we have
so we've got we've got great things here
and we shouldn't forget them and it
doesn't mean you have to bow to the
United States all the time it doesn't
mean you have to to say we're flawless
and all that but it means that you have
to respect what are our founding fathers
built because they built something
pretty great that gives more power to
you than the people above you and don't
just give that up because it sounds good
or it's easy
shout out to Agnes welcome aboard
patreon.com slash rubin report all right
i'm going to go a little bit longer and
then we've obviously had a long day here
i got an early flight to rochester and
then we'll go from there let's see
do-do-do-do-do-do did what's the
rationale counter to the intellectually
dishonest word police that aggressively
ignores context for example the monkey
it up story or Conor Daly's father
comments from the 1980s so I don't know
the second one as for the monkey it up
story so I just heard about this with
man an hour ago obviously I didn't know
the news until until that and the you
should watch the video where I give a
good explanation on this but look Howard
Cosell as I mentioned was fired from I
think it was CBS after being basically
the biggest sports broadcaster in the
nation because he said something about a
black football player monkeying around
or something and it turned out because
the guy had jumped over somebody else
while playing football and it turned out
that that's what he used to say about
his grandkids as they were like
wrestling with each other he used to
call them monkeys was he racist you know
did is there is sensitivity there
perhaps but yes this intellectual
dishonesty where we're like where were
gerrymandering the truth actually that's
I guess what we're doing is is terrible
and someone should not be fired for a
verbal gaffe you know look it's up to a
private company to do whatever they want
to do okay that's one thing but unless
you have a history of racism or do
something that is truly truly racist not
just use a word in a way that someone
else doesn't like it we're going to get
to a place where everyone will be afraid
to speak actually that is one of the
things that came up when I when I would
see people at the hardware store at
Starbucks or whatever for the past month
and people would come up to me and there
as there has it off the grid and don't
do that many people would tell me
something like oh I wish I could you
know just get off the grid I can't do it
right out of my job I can't do it i
don't know i mean everyone i think can
do it or at least for a little time and
i maybe not for a month but a lot of
people were saying how they've really
self-selected out that they're getting
on facebook much less they're tweeting
much less they're checking news for us
look that's good in a short term at some
level because if it's if you're
distracted by that or it's making you
frustrated or giving you a headache or
giving you short-term memory-loss are
all sorts of things
okay all good to control that that's
fine where it becomes bad is when if all
the good people start self selecting out
then we got all the the bad people and
the haters and the angry people that are
running the whole conversation now we
got a problem there again this is partly
why we wanted to do this Rubin selecting
because I think we can start building
some community around some of the right
ideas so it's Rubin report.com slash
donate or patreon.com/scishow burn
report Kirk thank you Mike thank you
alright here we go
level 5 or above I'm going to Skype with
you right after this level 2 or above
you're gonna get this Rubin report
t-shirt which is not being printed
anymore level 1 or above verbal shout
out right now will do will do maybe 10
or 15 minutes more here so get in some
good questions here if you can so if
trump can avoid any major scandal and
keeps us out of war what do you what
chance do you think he has of being
reelected in 2020 so I'm just catching
up on some of the stuff - Ben enlighten
me on that's happened with Trump over
the last little while with this Michael
Cohen stuff and the rest of it I would
say short of being impeached if the
Democrats win the house by a landslide
and then just impeach the guy short of
that if the Democrat path is to keep
going down with the Democratic Socialist
then I suspect Trump will be reelected I
think that that fringe thing which seems
like it's mainstream because the
mainstream loves it but it's a fringe
set of lefty ideas progressivism is not
mainstream most people do not buy into
this most people do not buy int identity
politics most people do not buy into big
government most people don't they want
to live and let live and that's it and I
think the the Republicans are better
suited to carry that mantle they fail at
it often and they fight you know they'll
tell you about low taxes and low
spending and then they never freakin do
it but they've got a little bit of a
better insight or track on that than the
Democrats if the Democrats decide to
become a little more moderate find some
old decent liberals find their JFK find
their Daniel Patrick Moynihan etc then I
think there's a chance but I don't think
anyone well let's look at it this way I
don't think anyone that voted for Trump
in 2016 if the Democrats keep going down
that road is going to be like oh the
Democrats are the better option than
this right if the economy is okay and
we're not in a next
war and there's been no major terror
attack or something that's really a
game-changer that we can't figure out
right this moment
I don't think anyone that voted for
Trump suddenly could go oh that that's
much better I was wrong last time that's
much better
now the issue will be is if if the Trump
people or the Republicans or
conservatives wherever if they're just
if they're voters just don't come out
because they're just depressed they're
like yeah we don't like Trump anymore we
don't like this thing but it's not going
to vote and then the Democrats are
really enthused well then that will
happen so there's really no way to fully
predict any of this as I said to men you
know these these off your elections the
2018 thing conventional wisdom is that
there's going to be a massive blue wave
again I don't think that people who are
generally conservative or old-school
liberal or libertarian are gonna look at
the Democratic alternative which we used
to be a little more moderate but now has
gone really left and go that's better
than this even if this thing is
extremely imperfect and surrounded in
mystery and all sorts of weird things
but if the people that like that don't
vote well then then you just you just
don't know
all right guys about ten minutes more
patreon.com slash Rubin report or Rubin
report calm slash no Nate we're building
up our community on Rubin select which
is our new patreon program and there's
behind the scenes videos there's live
AMAs there's these big group hangouts
where I get to talk to small groups of
twenty of you at the same time or ten of
you or five of you depending on what
level you jump in at I talk to people
all over the world on video everyone
sees everybody it's real cool and fun
and and really really great so hopefully
you guys will jump in on that if you
just if you like these ideas and you
want to throw in for what probably costs
you one beer get in on it okay here we
go
what about NASCAR driver Conor Daly lost
his sponsor because saying his dad said
before he's burnt I haven't heard about
this yet that sounds completely bananas
but very much the sort of where we're at
in in 2018 but that sounds completely
insane can you please have guests on
about kamek gate and star wars what are
your thoughts on how these things are
filled with identity politics people
have asked me this a little bit before
look I last yet I just sucked I didn't
want it to suck but there were so many
sucky
things in there that I can't even begin
to just real quick in terms of suckiness
who the hell Snoke you're not gonna tell
us really how is he not not Darth
Plagueis just boring and lazy the way
they kick the can down with with Ray's
parents ridiculous purple haired Laura
Dern shouldn't have been in the movie
that should have been admiral ackbar
it's an aging old admiral who doesn't
have any ideas left that's what you're
thinking the whole time and then at the
last moment he does this amazing
maneuver and blows up one of the star
destroyers but instead you have this
character that you just met that you
don't care about who's a big celebrity
and it's like akbar gets killed
off-camera Leia there's no force in
space stupid why did Luke project
himself there force if he was gonna die
anyway not why not have the fight have
the freaking fight and die pull an
obi-wan let yourself die at the last
moment so many stupid things that the
frickin gambling planet which was
utterly pointless yeah all that aside
the identity politics part of it
actually is quite annoying as well it
seems as if the way they framed it is
these are all white generally older but
white men right that's what the
first-order is white men and they're
fighting this diverse group of young
people who just want freedom and it's
like we get it we get what you're doing
here yeah just you know what though I
loved force awakens and I think JJ can
clean this thing up
alright shout out to Leo and I'm
specifically told here not DiCaprio so I
don't know where that guy is but thank
you leo
alright couple minutes more level one if
you jump on right now in the next couple
minutes I'm gonna give you a verbal
shout out right now
level two we're going to give you the
Reuben report shirt that it's not being
printed anymore we only got a couple
left level five we're gonna give you a
level 5 or above I'm gonna Skype with
you and thank you right after this okay
let's see here
[Music]
what's your opinion on Peterson's
solution for in cells specifically
regarding forced monogamy so I think
it's actually in forced monogamy not
forced monogamy which is different
forced monogamy would be mean actually
forcing people to be monogamous
enforcement aagama is basically talking
and strengthening the ideas
marriage is basically what it means I
know that's a hard for a lot of new york
times writers to grasp so I would want
to hear him fully extrapolated I've
heard him talk about it a little bit
he's talked about it on the tour a
little bit basically I think when people
talk about insolence I want to get this
totally right they're talking about sort
of this group what they feel are young
males who often are into sort of video
games who have just removed themselves
from the equation they are getting their
sexual needs met with porn they're not
interacting with the opposite sex I
wonder I guess actually you could
probably be a gay insel is that is that
a thing a gay so that must be a thing
too right
but in effect you're just sort of
cutting yourself off from these personal
relationships and just sort of living
online something something to that
effect you know I think that Jordans
book I think 12 rules for life is a
pretty good antidote to that the book is
called you know the subtitle is an
antidote to chaos and really what he's
talking about there is get your life
under control want to fix the world but
guess what you can't do it if your rooms
not clean and that's just sort of a
metaphor for some bigger things go be
the top Lobster all of the all of those
little funny catchphrases the guys using
actually have a much bigger meaning so
I'd want to hear him talk about it
specifically a little bit more before I
comment on his feelings about it
Najib thank you very much welcome aboard
all right this will be my last official
pitch people so if you want in you've
got five more minutes and I know you
want in you want in get part be part of
a same feed where people are talking
about these ideas Rueben report.com
slash donate or patreon.com slash rubin
report we got the feed there you can
interact with people you can do it
anonymously or not we're gonna we're
gonna boot the haters I don't want their
money you guys will be your funding this
show your funding our expansion why we
were just able to hire some new people
and redo the set we didn't have to do
this but you guys enable us to do things
and get new graphics and get new music
and all of that stuff you guys are the
ones that absolutely enable us to do it
and we got some slots open at the level
5 or above tiers where you can get in
the goop Google hangout I do this
monthly I try with you guys all over the
world video chats we talk back and forth
and all that good
okay let's see what are we doing here
[Music]
man there's a lot of stuff here it's
hard pick up things okay Rucka and
malice stated they are both interested
in a debate would you host and hosted
objectivism versus anarchism so you're
talking about rucka rucka ali former
guests of the rubin report and i assume
you're talking about michael malice also
former guests of the rubin report they
wanna have a debate on objectivism vers
anarchism that's kind of interesting
because obviously objectivism sort of is
almost like a you could say a strain of
libertarianism with sort of more of a
more of an ethos around morality versus
anarchism where malice is an anarchist
let me let me talk to the guys privately
before I make any any promises here let
me just see what's going on I could for
all I know I'm walking into something
they've been at each other's throats and
I'm gonna commit to it and then god only
knows what's gonna happen so we'll we'll
see oh I guess they agreed to have it
online all right let me see about it
we're kind of booked at least through
October right now but let me see about
it okay let's see how this is
interesting our property based ideals
libertarianism lays a fair etc in need
of an update because of the advent of
products which don't fall under laws of
production software automated services
etc that's interesting because now we've
got sort of these decentralized things
and these things that don't need
constant more more and more production
and we're in you know look this is a
little bit this is sort of ancillary
related to when people are yelling about
$15 minimum wage but what I always bring
this back to and I've heard many
economists talk about this is that we're
going into a more automated economy so
the more you say that the jobs that are
the most disposable which are the jobs
that generally have minimum wage the
more you say we're gonna have to inflate
those wages the more of the companies
and this is what any company would do
this is what you would do if you owned a
company you would look to cut costs and
especially if you're now having this
wage thing that's artificially not by
what
you can pay but the government's coming
in and saying you're gonna have to pay
more now you're seeing your profits go
down you're gonna try to figure out how
do you how do you get that to go this
way again well how are you gonna do it
you're gonna fire all your employees at
McDonald's in order with iPads we see
this happening with fast-food joints
already I've seen this happening at a
whole bunch of you know I've been
traveling all over the country I see
this happening in all sorts of places
now where you don't talk to people you
just press in buttons and then some you
know then one guy at the end hands you
something but that guy can be replaced
too and then there's one guy that
probably fixes all the machines so I do
think we have to we have to rethink we
have to rethink almost everything we're
in an interesting precipice and in human
society right now and we have to rethink
how we're interacting with each other
how do we how do the is there goodness
left in these crumbling institutions in
a time now where people don't trust
mainstream media how it's now on you to
figure out who to trust right I I assume
some of you you watch this you like what
I'm talking about you like the
conversations I'm happening but I
certainly shouldn't be the only person
that you trust and you shouldn't be
getting all your only information for me
I certainly hope that you don't so we
have to explore all sorts of new things
but that's why I'm so hopeful for
everything right now it's like there's
such hope there's such energy if you see
you know I read all these articles and
it's like comedy is dead and television
is dead and there's nothing new or
original it's like man with such chaos
right now or perceived chaos you can be
creative come to one of my stand-up
shows see what's going on I'm barely
doing a set I go up there with maybe
five jokes and I'm fiddling with the
crowd for an hour and a half and people
have a freaking ball and I have fun and
it's live and it's interactive and we
people are heckling me and I'm heckling
back and and it's all good natured and
fun and the same time people right now
stand-up comedy's dead and it's that
stand-up comedy said it's that the ideas
of leftism
are dying in real time and because so
many comics come from that line of
thinking now they've moved over to
whining about it because that's also
part of the part and parcel of the whole
thing Lance I want to give you a shout
out all right people
two minutes more who's going to allow me
Rubin report.com slash donate or
patreon.com slash Rubin Report level 1
or above you're getting a verbal shout
out only two minutes left
level 2 or above you're getting the
Rubin report shirt not being
any more level fiber above Skype
immediately after this livestream let's
see
would you ever considering hosting a
mock debate between two ideologically
opposed guests who have to argue for the
other side that would be interesting so
this would be along the lines of
something that a bunch of us have talked
about but Eric Weinstein was really big
on the idea of really straw Manning your
opponent that really if you want to have
a true serious argument that you'd want
to steal man your opponent's views not
mock your opponent's views not
personally attack your opponent we see
plenty of this out there and just doing
anything for clicks or anything you'd
really want to steal man those views go
this this set of ideas this bulleted
list of ideas this right here in this
box is exactly what this person is
saying I disagree with all of these
things but this is what this person is
saying now you can't attack their
motives or any of that you say this is
what they're saying and then you say
here's how I disagree with it that we
pretty cool to actually have two people
that disagree with things steel man each
other's views and then argue against
themselves that would be actually pretty
cool let me let me think it through I've
obviously got a couple people in the
chamber that I think maybe could do it
so that would be pretty great all right
I'm gonna say my goodbyes so if you're
jumping in Ruben report.com / patreon
rube report com / donate or patreon.com
slash Ruben report you got to do it
quick I think we're gonna build a really
great diverse community there I think
you guys can see we've reinvested in the
studio here we've got a huge huge guest
I think potentially our biggest guest
ever next week which um I'm super
psyched about you know but I'm going
back out on tour Petersen I'm hitting up
all these stand-up clubs again we're
trying to figure out how to build out
some bigger IDW things I think there's
some technological answers on some of
the big questions you guys have been
asking for a while
I'm truly feeling more energized than
ever it was great to be off the grid I
today it was like when I woke up this
morning I was at not nervous but I was a
little like ah here we go again even
though I love what I do like I don't
know that there's anyone that loves what
they
do more than I do but I was like whoa
here we go the monster is back let's
let's do it I'm gonna figure out
personally out how to manage that a
little bit more I told Shapiro today you
know he does a regular Shabbat where
he's off the grid from Friday night
usually to Saturday night he sometimes
he said he extends that over the weekend
I've been trying to do the weekend thing
I'm gonna try to do that a little bit
more just manage all of this stuff
because I really think that that one of
the reasons that you guys watch this is
because I've provided you with a little
relief or reprieve of the craziness and
believe me I'm it's good for you but
it's good for me so let's let's keep
building that together we're gonna keep
doing great shows here do more stuff on
the road as I said and and hopefully
hopefully I will continue to grow as
you've seen and I will I promise you
that I will be I will be honest about my
opinions and and thoughtful when I'm
talking to people and curious and all of
that good stuff
if you pledged people email us at
contact at Rubin report.com and we'll
take care of it whether you're getting a
t-shirt or whether you're getting a
Skype with me in a few minutes which I'm
happy to do email us your t-shirt size
and your mailing address we'll get that
shirt out to you immediately oh Linda I
think you're the last one Linda welcome
on board Linda and also I mentioned it
before I wasn't really thinking about it
beforehand but we've got all the old set
stuff so make us an offer we can't
refuse who will figure it out we're
gonna to figure out what to do with some
of the stuff you know and if you you
know if you who knows just send us an
email contact everyone record calm we'll
see what's what all right guys thanks
it's been a great first day back I got a
couple hours now to to have dinner and
get out of the studio and stretch the
legs and then I'm off to Rochester with
Peterson tomorrow night I will be in
Westbury Long Island that's my hometown
show on Thursday night then on Friday
night I'm doing an event in New York
City with Eric Weinstein and Faizal
Alamut R and Melissa Chen which I'll
tweet about in a little bit I saw they
tweeted about it earlier then I got a
couple days then a bunch of shows in
Florida then I'm back here I know I'm
back here before that got the big show
that I just mentioned then a couple
shows in Florida and then we keep the
beat going on we got it we got tons of
great guests coming up I'm super psyched
for a lot of the stuff we're going to
this is just the beginning we're at the
beginning again so I thank you guys and
if you haven't checked it out already do
check out Ruben report comm well check
out the new Dave Rubin comm and see
what's going on over there for for show
dates and meet and greets and all that
good stuff and thanks for watching and
over and out
[Music]